[Music]
kids
come here we got pizza
[Music]
come on all right hold on hold on no
don't fight for all of y'all
me mom's getting ready to go in here and
watch her show all right y'all be quiet
eat that pizza
so finally i get to strike back that's
right
angela gets to strike back to all the
hating comments
are you ready are you really ready
because here i come hello guys i just
finished having my bad so i want to look
fresh and
good okay let's go guys come along
here we go one two
three let's
that's my go
go annie look at annie see and he's
doing it now already
go angie go get it girl oh
shut up jim it ain't uh veronica chillin
he's really sitting there saying uh
cause you're sitting there but what he's
really saying in his mind is
oh
okay here's a tweet angela's filling
around to make sure her one egg is still
in place
no honey i was feeling around cause i
was feeling myself
i thought i felt like i was 100 pounds
listen
i thought i was gonna be stripping next
cause i really did enjoy that i was
i thought i was right then
[Music]
you